the whole idea around decentralization
is essentially no one person or
organization controls the system that's
it right if you think of centralization
um it's important to kind of recognize
why is centralization important or why
has it been effective right if
amazon wants to be built or we want to
accomplish a lot of the things that have
been great throughout this industrial
revolution we needed central
order or central kind of um coordination
of resources both financial capital
human capital
um and also plans and uh and execution
and so these centralized entities end up
being built into hierarchical structures
there's somebody or a group of people at
the top and they basically are able to
um you know kind of decree down to the
rest of the company here's what we're
going to work on here's what we're not
going to work on and that's basically
what the corporate world is as we know
it right
jeff bezos got immense leverage with
amazon because he had human capital and
financial capital and a hierarchical
centralized structure that's actually a
good thing we would not have amazon
without it right amazon's actually been
a huge net positive for the world in my
opinion
name every other tech company same thing
right they're all centralized
hierarchical structures
now what we're getting though is a
technology change that allows for the
coordination of resources that doesn't
require the hierarchical structure
instead of one person making decisions
what if everyone gets to make the
decision
well it depends what are you trying to
accomplish sometimes decentralization's
better sometimes it's not right there's
a very strong argument that in certain
situations centralization's the the more
efficient better uh kind of structure
but now that we have decentralization
with this technology
what you do is you can actually build
much larger networks
so
the difference between a hierarchical
structure of let's say
amazon that is trying to build out all
of these super
kind of moonshot type ideas aws and
logistics and all of this
compared to maybe something where a
network ends up making much more sense
right so take bitcoin
well there's miners there's node
operators and there's holders these are
three different groups
and the miners are financially
incentivized to
run computers to run the network
it's pretty interesting there's a
financial incentive for people all
around the world there's literally
millions and millions of machines around
the world that are all doing this it's
the strongest computing network in the
world why
because
every 10 minutes or so there is uh a
certain amount of bitcoin 6.25 bitcoin
that ends up actually being given out to
folks um that are running that network
to the people who are running the uh the
bitcoin blockchain
and so that financial incentive right
now ends up being somewhere 45 50
million dollars a day in bitcoin ends up
being given out to these people based on
the how much competing power and some
nuance there so when you create a
network that doesn't have a hierarchical
structure there's no ceo of bitcoin
there's no marketing department there
was no uh here's the master plan okay
tom you go build the site in washington
state and you know larry you go build
the site and
china and mark you go build the one in
texas
there's none of that it was purely tom
says you know what i want my piece of
the bitcoin block reward every day and
we know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go
figure it out i'm gonna go get energy or
power i'm gonna buy these machines then
i'm gonna run this and i'm going to have
a profitable business
and so rather than
rely on that hierarchical structure by
creating a network we created the
strongest computer network in the world
in 12 years
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn how
cryptocurrency will revolutionize the
future of money
enjoy
rule number two look at adoption with
rural paul if i was to say give us your
top five or six
uh worthwhile watching obviously you're
gonna say bitcoin and ethereum and all
that that's nice but what what's your
thoughts what would you what gem can you
give all these people
watching yeah so the gem of how to
understand this space
is easy you don't need to be a genius
you just need to look at adoption
so this space is all priced in something
called metcalf's law metcalfe's law
really came about from computing but
mobile phones was the easy example
one mobile phone worthless two
reasonably good if it's somebody you
want to speak to not very useful you
don't want to speak to them
if everybody has a mobile you can now
reach everybody on earth
okay then those same mobiles you could
put data on and have the internet on and
that changed everything
then the computer world came along and
interacted with this world and now we've
got these two networks and it's made
mobile computing turn into this
a supercomputer on your phone
and what this is is the network of money
and they all follow the same thing
metcalfe's law is the number of nodes on
the network the number of users
and the amount of connectivity between
the users
creates the value of the network so what
you do is look at these cryptocurrencies
and say right how many people are using
it a lot of people is that network
growing and are people building stuff on
it if you can answer those questions
with yes
then you've got good investment and the
ones that i see that in right now
um are
bitcoin ethereum
solana
terra
and
probably polka dot
or avalanche
and those are the ones that larger
market cap
we're seeing real use cases
lots of people adopting it and lots of
people developing applications on it so
those are those are the bets but really
you only need to take one bet
just take ethereum
it's like ethereum is like the internet
it's the it's like the internet of money
it's like the software platform that
everything is being built on
and it may not go up the most
but it's going to go up a hell of a lot
because it's got massive network effects
it's easy to understand it's easy to
trade it's easy to buy it's liquid
and you don't have to learn too many new
things rule number three embrace bitcoin
with michael saylor i think that when
you embrace bitcoin as your property
strategy
you can get away from the maintenance
cost
the likelihood is going to be impaired
decreases exponentially
uh the law it's a lot harder to seize a
billion dollars of bitcoin than it is to
seize a billion dollars of land or
billion of art or a billion of gold or a
billion of a building or a building of
stock
exponentially harder if i had uh if i
have a billion dollars in a bank it's
easy to seize a billion in a bank
if i wanted to take all the money uh
from everybody in argentina
i could do it overnight if it was
sitting in cash or credit but if i
wanted to seize all the money from
everybody in argentina and they all used
bitcoin and held their own keys i would
have to incarcerate
70 million people for 90 days
and i'd have to sweat it out of them so
how hard is it
to jail
70 million people for three months and
how many people do i need to do that
very difficult uh a thousand times
harder a million times higher
10 million times probably 10 million to
100 million times harder
to seize the asset than it is to seize
cash or credit or securities
seizing companies and seizing buildings
is easy right the cubans seized all the
all the buildings right everybody lost
their private property in cuba and
castro took over that's simple
it's easy to nationalize an oil company
it's easy to seize all the gold right we
know how to do that
it's very difficult
to see these passwords in people's heads
so
so i look at bitcoin and i think well
it's it's a universal property it'll
last forever it's very hard to seize
it's very hard to tax
it's uh it's easy to move
and that makes it universally appealing
because on the day you wake up and you
find that it's uh illegal to own bitcoin
in your country
you can either take it with you to
another country
try taking a billion dollars of gold to
another country with you try taking a
billion dollars a building on the
country so you can either take it with
you or
you can send it
somewhere
or you can sell it
and so the ability to send it
to take it or to
to keep it or to sell it all those are
three rights
that you sacrifice when you buy a house
or a building or land or securities or
credit
or cash
you don't have those right or art
or collectibles or sports teams right
whatever it is you think you have
you don't have property rights with
those things
and ultimately the idea of bitcoin is
nothing is an elegant
121 millionth
of all of the value on the network for
as long as the network may
last
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number four invest with
anthony scarmucci i thought there was
going to be way more institutional
interest at the beginning of the year
january 2021
then manifest but now i'll make a bold
prediction anthony
i think there's going to be
institutional interest over the next 12
to 18 months because you now have gotten
the regulatory box checked and that
checking of that box is going to lead to
institutions saying hey i got to get in
this thing i've got to own a piece of
this i've got to understand it and what
would george soros say
he would say invest and investigate
later you've heard that aphorism and i
think you're now going to start to see
it but i didn't see it over the last
eight or nine months
and that's just me being straight up
with the ant rule number five adapt with
robert breedlove you can think of
bitcoin as this
new technology that so radically
increases the cost to benefit ratio
violence and that
if someone's properly custody again in a
multi-signature format or whatever
there's not any carrot at the end of
robbing them you're not going to get
anything right you can go and
in bitcoin circles they call this the
five dollar wrench attack because you
buy the wrench for five dollars and you
beat the guy over the head with a wrench
until he gives up his bitcoin but if
he's custodied it properly there's no
incentive even to conduct a five dollar
wrench attack so
in this gigantic geopolitical upheaval
that i anticipate
occurring
due to the monetization of bitcoin i
think it could be
very uncertain at first you know
governments
are going to use their power in certain
ways
that could be unfavorable let's say but
over time as bitcoin continues to
monetize and more and more people are
holding their wealth in this inviolable
property
that would
i would tend to believe that the
incentives towards peaceful cooperation
would begin to outweigh the incentives
to coercion
so although it could be a bit rocky in
the beginning i think the long-term
outcome is way more fruitful for for
humans you know we're and
something you said earlier too that
maybe people don't want sovereignty
full sovereignty i think people
i think incentives
are the fertile soil from which
our humanity springs actually
all right so we think is maybe a bit
egotistical that we think that however
we are this is the way humans are it's
the way they've always been but again
that's totally not true right
pre-printing press most of us were
illiterate we didn't have our cognitive
software was completely unrecognizable
to what we are today no one could sit
here and have a conversation like this
much less with all these amazing tools
we've created in the marketplace since
then so
i think that by changing the fundamental
soil which are the incentives again like
the logic of violence and all these
other things that we actually change our
character traits and behaviors
um i've said that and to try and draw
commonality here
i said organizations and institutions
are all property strategies you know i
think that even dna itself is kind of a
survival strategy or property strategy
over time
right we're all all organisms geared
towards reproduction reproduction
necessitates territory we need to take
territory humans express territory in
property right that's how we share and
build uh declare property and create
more wealth actually by trading through
property rights so i think that we
our strategies
ultimately conform to the invariance
on the game board if you will and sailor
talks about one of these is gravity
right like
gravity is the one invariant
that all
of these strategies whether you're a
human being whether you're a building
whether you're a government like you're
you're adapting your strategy to gravity
it's an invariant right you can't if you
change gravity it would destroy all the
humans and buildings and all the things
you can kind of consider bitcoin
maybe i'm out on a limb here but i think
21 million this fixed supply asset as
the emergence of a new
seemingly perfected invariant in the
market for money so it forces all of us
to change our strategies to adopt this
invariant and in the space so this is at
the individual level the institutional
level and at the nation state level
um
sounds a bit radical but i think that if
you come to see
you know dna as a survival strategy
propagating through blood flesh and bone
and that all the other creations we make
are just
um you know in biology they call this
the extended phenotype we have the
genotype which is the genetic code the
strategy itself
we implement it in the phenotype the
body the teeth eyes we have the extended
phenotype which are our tools and
technologies or even our institutions
that it's all a strategy
and that those strategies will adopt
themselves to the invariants that we
create for ourselves i think bitcoin is
just the perfect invariant money rule
number six evolve with gary vaynerchuk
gary you tweeted in 2013
that you just bought using bitcoin
google smart pants and had it delivered
by a drone in 21 minutes first of all
it must be a very expensive pair of
pants in today's dollar terms and
seconds
you know
you know what was your experience with
paying something with bitcoin should it
be used as a currency what what are your
thoughts on that
should be i apologize should my
experience was in 2013 good
yeah should be should bitcoin be used as
a currency
it is
it's not even a should this is not about
predictions people accept bitcoin all
the time it's it's already happened the
question becomes
what happens next i i think this you
know bitcoin is so much further along
than the majority of things that have
come before it as an accepted currency
to me
i don't get to say nor do most humans
get to say what should or shouldn't be
accepted if enough people believe in it
then it becomes
you know i always remind people
somebody
used to live in the world
before gold meant anything you know we
we didn't have great documentation
but gold
was a created ecosystem should gold be
expressed what should be the currency of
the world
is my question to you
whatever enough of the people in the
world accept right humans create their
ecosystems i don't think i don't think
this is a game of should this is a game
of how has it always happened people
used to trade berries for sheeps people
used to trade furs
for for people
uh people used to trade high-end wine
for workers to build things i mean i i
laugh at people's naivete to think what
is going on today or what we grew up
with is the end-all be-all uh that's
just laughable the human race will
continue to evolve and if anything i
think it makes more sense that things
that are digital become the currency as
we go that route as a race and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus clips is store value
in bitcoin with mark cuban how do you
see this
bitcoin narrative now versus the
ethereum narrative like um
and how do you see them going into the
next few years so so a couple things
where people got mad at me and were i i
was at odds with the bitcoin community
is i never saw it as a currency i saw it
as a store of value digital gold right
and just a supply and demand issue and
obviously you know the algorithmic
scarcity is built just to define supply
and the more demand you can build for it
the the the higher the price is going to
go and that's not a bad thing but it was
never really designed to be a currency
and you saw that in 2017 with all the
forks and all the arguments about block
size and everything
and so i i was fine with it as a store
value and
um
really just to me it was just a question
of when it started becoming more
more commonplace for people to buy it
because that's what was going to lead to
a significant increase in price and
that's what happened um and then with
ethereum
i really you know with the ico blow up
and the ico you know balloon it was
interesting and i actually lost some
money at that time um just experimenting
with some things but nothing horrible
and but i learned some there but it
really wasn't until this summer when
smart contracts really started to evolve
and become more more available that
things really took off and that's you
know like i said before that's where i
dug in
and to me
in terms of how it all plays out
bitcoin's great as a platform
and it's it's accepted now it's an
alternative asset it's going to replace
gold in the portfolios of a lot of
people and that hopefully will push the
price up as long as the whales continue
to huddle but that that's a different
type of platform and it's utility really
only happens when you wrap it at least
as of now
what would it need to take or what would
have to happen for you to go from the
seven percent target today to 20 percent
performance
performance i mean that's basically you
know i'm not a cowboy here i'm actually
allocating capital towards achieving a
distributable return between six and
eight percent a year and so
you know we have a lot of volatility in
bitcoin and right now we're kind of 61
back from the lows and that's great but
not every crypto asset has to be that
volatile so when you start to build out
your portfolio let's go to usdc
um you know
you you actually can take that as a
relatively stable asset and write
contracts on it for 60 days 30 days 90
days and generate three and a half four
percent yield which is what i'm doing
right now and so i look at it as a
portfolio approach some of these things
have volatility some don't but you know
the biggest problem which is
holding all of us back in the crypto
industry right now
is compliance at the institutional level
you know you go in and you say look um
everybody's talking about this all right
i'm running let's say i'm running a
billion dollar mandate that's not
uncommon and i want to put 10 percent
into crypto
you have to be able to find a platform
that can link to your internal reporting
and your external regulatory you know
it's not like i got a hun if i'm putting
a 10 allocation on a billion that's a
hundred million i'm not going to
download an app on my phone and put 100
billion 100 million dollars into it
i'm going to have to have an
institutional compliant platform and the
industry is not there yet pomp it's got
a lot of work to do on that front and
the more we move towards that the more
capitalism will be coming in
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want a deeper dive into bitcoin check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there much much more
valuable than it is today
do we get institutions to adopt then you
know kind of developing nations and then
there's a default and there's an
inflection point like how do you think
we sequentially get there what does that
like order of operations almost look
like